dix équipes yvelinoise s'affrontaient ce
week-end à voisins le bretonneux dans le
cadre de la coupe des yvelines de futsal
des moins de 17 ans montigny alignait
une équipe composée uniquement de
joueurs de foot à 11
cette compétition fait donc office de
parenthèse dans la saison en plein air
140 très vite dans le match car foot à
onze on a quand même 90 minutes et on
arrive
même si on rate le premier quart d'heure
on sait que derrière il nous reste un
peu de temps pour aménager le mac
on vient pour aussi satisfaire nos
joueurs les plus méritants parce que ça
aussi une récompense
ça aussi ça peut passer par une
récompense parce que ils viennent deux
fois par semaine sans traîner son
tout le temps l'intensité beaucoup plus
présente dans le futsal qu'en plein air
venir se frotter aux spécialistes permet
donc de travailler d'autres aspects du
jeu comme la circulation rapide à une ou
deux touches de balle ça a été compliqué
on n'a pas très bien joué on s'est pas
super appliqué on n'a pas été percutant
dans les actions qu'on a appris 5 0 mais
s'est passé pas vraiment mérité on a
essayé mais bon il manquait la rapidité
dans les comptes
éliminés dès les matches de poule
montini va pouvoir se recentrer sur le
championnat de foot à 11 de leur côté
voisins le bretonneux et versailles se
qualifie pour les demi finales le 17
mars prochain